c'était une visite express à l'aéroport
de roissy charles de gaulle celle de
jean castex le premier ministre
accompagné d'olivier vers en épis de
jean baptiste jebbari le ministre du
transport ils ont été accueillis ici par
monsieur hirsch le président de
l'assistance publique-hôpitaux de paris
une visite dans le cadre du contrôle de
tout ce qui a été mis en place y ciel
aéroport pour contrôler les passagers
venant de l'étranger dans le cadre de la
lutte contre le corona virus après la
visite de l'aéroport et après l'avis
d'un stand mis en place par la rs un
stand qui permet aux passagers sur la
base du volontariat d'être dépisté ils
ont donné une conférence de presse ils
ont annoncé que des mesures allaient
être renforcées que seize pays sont
listées dans ces mesures de renforcement
le premier ministre a également
déconseillé aux français de se rendre
dans certaines destinations notamment la
catalogne suite à leur connaissance de
cas de coronavirus je vous propose est
d'écouter la déclaration du premier
ministre
nous savons que dans un certain nombre
de ces pays il n'existe pas de stratégie
de dépistage et que donc l'accès aux
tests et difficile
en conséquence de quoi nous avons décidé
de généraliser les tests à l'arrivée et
c'est ce dispositif qui est en train de
se mettre en place et je les vues de
manière satisfaisante qui va monter en
puissance pour être totalement
opérationnelle dans les prochains jours
et au plus tard le 1er août qu'avec mes
collègues ministres
je suis venu constater ce dispositif a
donc constaté pensent eux va donc
permettre une séparation des flux d'une
part de tous les pays arrivant de céder
rouge effectueront d'abord les
formalités douanières et ensuite des
formalités sanitaire consistante à faire
un test systématique les personnes dont
le test s'avère négatif bien
or en la vie normale de tous nos
concitoyens les autres font l'objet du
dispositif se rit de 14 m il va
permettre aux autorités sanitaires de
les isoler de les observer et jusqu'à ce
que la situation redevienne normale
une visite à l'aéroport alors que ce
matin le gouvernement se réunissait à
matignon mais aussi à l'elysée une
cellule de crise a été ouverte pour
essayer de lutter contre la propagation
de ce coronavirus le gouvernement craint
une deuxième vague c'est pour ça que le
premier ministre a déclaré que les
contrôles allaient être généralisé que
seize pays était est listé c'est ce pays
qui devront être surveillés de près et
puis bien sûr le premier ministre a
déclaré qu'il fallait éviter certaines
zones comme la catalogne
je vous rappelle que ces contrôles ne
sont toujours pas obligatoire que la
france a ouvert ses frontières de rugby
depuis plus d'un mois des contrôles qui
sont sur la base du volontariat
ici à l'aéroport de roissy charles de
gaulle comme dans le reste du pays